let's see if we can give ourselves a
little bit of practice converting
between radians and degrees and degrees
and radians and just as a review let's
just remind ourselves a relationship and
i always do this before i have to
convert between the two if i do one
revolution of a circle how many radians
is that going to be
well we know one revolution of a circle
is 2 pi
2 pi
radians
and how many degrees is that if i do one
revolution around a circle
well we know that that's 360. i can
either write it with a little degree
symbol right like that or i could write
it
just like that and this is really enough
information for us to think about how to
convert between radians and degrees if
we want to simplify this a little bit we
can divide both sides by 2
and you could have pi
pi
radians
are equal to 180 degrees
or another way to think about it going
halfway around a circle in radians is pi
radians or you've the the arc that
subtends that angle is pi radius this is
and that's also 180 degrees
and if you want to really think about
well how many how many degrees are there
per radian you can divide both sides of
this by pi
so if you divide both sides of this by
pi you get one radian
one
radian it would have to go from singular
or from plural to singular 1 radian is
equal to 180 over pi degrees
so all i did is i
divided both sides by pi
and if you wanted to figure out how many
radians are there per degree you can
divide both sides by 180 so you'd get pi
over 180
radians
is equal to
degree so this is now i think we are
ready to start converting so let's
convert
let's convert 30 degrees let's convert
30 degrees to radians
so let's think about it so i'm going to
write it out and actually you might
remind this might remind you of kind of
unit analysis that you might do when you
first did unit conversion but it also
works out here so if i were to write 30
degrees this is how my brain likes to
work with it i like to write out the
word degrees and then i say well i want
to convert to radians so i really want
to figure out how many radians are there
per degree so let me write this down i
want to figure out how many radians how
many radians are do we have per degree
how many radians
do we have per
degree and i haven't filled out how many
that is but we see just the units will
cancel out if we have degrees times
radians per degree the degrees will
cancel out and i'll be just left with
radians if i multiply the number of
degrees i have times the number of
radians per degree we're going to get
radians and hopefully that makes
intuitive sense as well
and here we just have to think about
well
if i have if i have
think of it this way if i have pi
radians
pi radians how many degrees is that
well that's
180 degrees come straight out of this
right over here pi radians for every 180
degrees or pi over 180 radians per
degree but then this is going to get us
we're going to get 30. 30 times pi over
180 30
times
pi
pi over 180 which will simplify to 30
over 180 is 1 over 6. so this is equal
to pi
over 6 actually let me write the units
out this is 30 radians
which is equal to pi
over 6
radians
now let's go the other way
let's think about
if we have pi over 3 radians pi
over 3
radians and i want to convert that to
degrees so what am i going to get if i
convert that to degrees
well here we're going to want to figure
out how many degrees are there how many
degrees are there
per radian
and the way one way to think about it is
well think about the pi and the 180. for
every 180 degrees for every 180 degrees
you have pi radians 180 degrees over pi
radians these are essentially the
equivalent thing this essentially you're
just multiplying this quantity by one
but you're changing the units the
radians cancel out and then the pi's
cancel out and you're left with 180 over
3 degrees 180 over 3 is 60 and we could
either write out the word degrees or you
can write degrees just like that
now let's think about 45 degrees
so what about 45
degrees and i'll write it like that just
so you can figure it out as there figure
out with that notation as well how many
radians will this be equal to
well once again we're going to want to
we're going to want to think about how
many radians do we have per degree so
we're going to multiply this
times well we know we have pi radians
we know we have pi radians for every
180 degrees for every 180 degrees or we
could even write write it this way pi
radians for every 180 degrees
and here this might be a little less
intuitive the degrees cancel out and
that's why i'd like to usually write out
the word and you're left with 45 pi over
180 radians actually let me write this
with the words written out for me that's
more intuitive when i'm thinking about
it
in terms of
using the notation so 45 degrees times
we have pi radians
pi radians
for every 180 degrees for every 180
for every 180 degrees so we are left
with when you multiply
times pi
over
180 the degrees have cancelled out and
you're just left with radians
radians which is equal to what 45 is
half of 90 which is half of 180. so this
is one-fourth this is equal to pi
over 4
radians
let's do
let's do one let's do one more over here
so let's say that we had
negative
negative pi over 2
radians what's that going to be in
degrees
well once again we have to figure out
how many degrees
are each of these radians we know that
there are 180
degrees
degrees for every pi radians
for every pi radians so we're going to
get the radians cancel out the pi's
cancel out
and so you have negative 180 over 2 this
is negative
negative 90
degrees
or we could write it as negative 90
degrees anyway hopefully you found that
helpful and i'll do a couple of more
example problems here because the more
example for this the better and
hopefully become a little bit intuitive